[موسيقى]
بمجرد أن
تخترق سطح المحيط ،
فإنه ينفتح حقًا
أمامك ، سترى الكثير من الحياة
الملونة ، وتحتوي على الكثير من الحركات
التي تشعر بها وكأنها انتقال إلى عالم آخر ،
اسمي إيريكا وولسي ، وأنا جندي
بحري  عالم أحياء متخصص
في بيئة الشعاب المرجانية ، أنا أيضًا قائد
في الهيدرا ،
وهي منظمة غير ربحية مكرسة لفهم المحيطات ،
نريد تعزيز الاتصال
بالمحيطات حتى يتحول ما نعرفه عن محيطنا إلى ما نفعله
لحمايته
وليس الجميع  يمكنني الوصول إلى المحيط ، أريد
أن
أجد طرقًا لجلب المحيط للجميع
لأن المحيط
جيد جدًا لعدم
مشاركة التقنيات التي نستخدمها بما في
ذلك الواقع الافتراضي الذي يمكن أن يعيد إنشاء ما يشبه أن تكون
تحت الماء ،
وقد وجد أي شخص السلحفاة حتى الآن من خلال
موقعنا  انغمس في فيلم vr ،
أخذنا ما يقرب من مليون شخص
يغوصون فعليًا منذ يونيو عام 2020.
[موسيقى]
منذ الوباء ، أخذنا
عددًا أكبر من الأشخاص
يغوصون فعليًا في بعض الأحيان ،
هناك أشخاص
غواصون وواقعيون  أفتقد ما كانت تبدو عليه الشعاب المرجانية
في
بعض الأحيان ، هم أشخاص لم
يزروا المحيط أبدًا
ويعتقدون أنه أمر مخيف ، لكن هذه التجربة
تجعلهم يتساءلون عما إذا كان بإمكانهم
محاولة جمع هذه الصورة الرائعة بزاوية 360 درجة
التي تجعلك تشعر وكأنك
نستخدم كاميرا متخصصة للغاية في الغوص
وهي عبارة عن 13
كاميرا مثبتة في غلاف تحت الماء
عندما نقوم بتجميع هذه اللقطات معًا ،
يمكننا إنشاء
تأثير 360 حيث يمكنك النظر في جميع
الاتجاهات في الوقت الحالي
لسنا فقط منفصلين عن
محيطنا ولكن أيضًا  بعضنا البعض ،
لذا فإن هذه الغطسات الافتراضية هي أداة
رائعة لربطنا أكثر ببيئاتنا الطبيعية
لقد رأيت بعض التغييرات الدراماتيكية للغاية
في الأماكن التي أغوص فيها الشعاب المرجانية
التي تتدهور بسرعة خاصة
في السنوات الماضية بسبب
تأثيرات تغير المناخ  وعندما
يذهب المرجان ويختفي هذا اللون ،
تفعل الأسماك كذلك تفعل الحيوانات الأخرى
التي تعتمد على الشعاب المرجانية
بغض النظر عن بُعد المحيط
الذي تعيش فيه ،
فأنت تعتمد على  الكثير من طعامنا يأتي
معظم الأكسجين الذي نتنفسه
من المحيط.
لأن الارتباط البشري
بهذه
الأماكن الجميلة والتي يتعذر الوصول إليها غالبًا هو
الذي يؤدي إلى التغيير الإيجابي